le 49 3 ça n'a jamais été une arme
destinée à museler l'opposition
c'est une arme destinée à museler la
majorité c'est quand le gouvernement on
n'a pas de majorité à l'assemblée quand
il n'est pas sûr de faire adopter un
texte par l'assemblée qu'il utilise le
49-3 ces mots monsieur le premier
ministre ne sont pas les miens ce sont
les vôtres daté de 2016 puisque vous
parlez d'une arme
aujourd'hui ce lb des parlementaires
d'une vème république à bout de souffle
c'est vous qui le dégainer seul contre
tous contre la représentation nationale
contre la majorité des français opposés
à votre texte contre les grévistes et
les manifestants contre les engagements
pris devant les français par le candidat
devenu président et vous voudriez nous
faire porter le chapeau
nous aurions empêcher le débat de fond
entre deux allers retours au havre vous
auriez pu jeter un oeil à nos débats car
le débat de fond c'est nous qui l'avons
permis vous dites que nous aurions
débattu pendant des heures pour savoir
s'il fallait par exemple remplacer les
mots tous les ans par chaque année vous
mentez et vous le savez car si nous
avons en effet déposé ce type
d'amendements c'était pour disposer
d'autant d'occasions de prendre la
parole et de pouvoir animer le débat de
fond sous la menace permanente de votre
49,3 et le bilan est plutôt bon en
quinze jours nous avons pu faire avouer
que votre système n'est pas universel
que les agriculteurs ne verront pas la
couleur des 1000 euros promis que la
valeur du point sera indexée sur un
indice qui n'existe pas bref on comprend
mieux pourquoi vous avez souhaité
interrompre la discussion reste donc une
autre hypothèse
depuis le début de l'année on assiste à
une multiplication en cascade des
démissions des parlementaires en marche
ne sont ce pas plutôt ses départs qui
vous ont poussée au 49 3